[Musique]
les mille et une vie de Bernard Tapie
documentaire réalisé par Jean-Charles
Doria un film qui vient surtout nous
rappeler que partie de rien ou presque
l'homme d'affaires avait longtemps tout
gagné dans sa vie jusqu'au jour où il
est entré en politique alors à doubé par
un certain François Mitterrand nous
allons y revenir maintenant avec celui
qui fut l'un des derniers interviewer
Bernard Tapie avant sa disparition le
journaliste Yves réars bienvenue
yves-tréac bonjour Jean-Pierre bonjour à
tous vous êtes directeur adjoint de la
rédaction du Figaro éditorialiste votre
dernier ouvrage a pour titre une
certaine idée de la France publiée aux
éditions du Rocher et vous êtes aussi là
de ceux qui mène la série les grands
entretiens sur notre chaîne sur LCP et
c'est à l'occasion de l'une de ces
longues interviews que vous aviez reçu
Bernard Tapie quelques mois seulement
avant sa disparition avait-il émis des
remords des regrets à l'occasion de
cette interview ou à l'occasion de
entretiens avec lui non c'était pas un
homme de remords ni de regret c'est
quelqu'un qui fonçait dans la vie
ce qui est extraordinaire avec Bernard
Tapie c'est que si vous me permettez
l'expression il vivait sa vie il n'avait
aucun recul sur elle il n'est cherché il
ne cherchait pas à la conceptualiser à
lui raconter une histoire lui ce qu'il
l'intéressait et c'était une de ces
raisons d'être c'est gagner il fallait
gagner que ça soit en sport que ça soit
en politique que ce soit dans les
affaires que ça soit même
sentimentalement il fallait qu'il ait
raison il fallait Bernard Tapie c'est
l'homme du dernier mot il faut que ça
soit lui qui gagne et ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que quand on lui
fait raconter sa vie ce qui était le cas
de cette interview et bien il est pas là
du tout pour lui trouver un fil
conducteur lui trouver une logique non
non il a enquillé si vous me permettez
aussi cette expression les les vies
parce que il a été il a tout fait il a
été pilote automobile il s'est
conseiller à la chanson il a fait de la
télé il a il a acheté des des
entreprises il a fait de la politique
acteurs de théâtre il a le record de la
traversée de l'Atlantique on l'a oublié
ça avec son avec le Phocéen il a il a
fait du théâtre enfin il a il a il a
essayé il s'est essayé dans tout c'était
un homme qui bouffait la vie c'était un
dévoreur et c'est ça sa vie ça vie elle
se résume si on peut la résumer c'est un
bouffeur de vie voilà alors quand même
la politique est-ce que ça pas été la
marge de trop pour Bernard Tapie oui
parce que c'est là où il a commencé à
chuter c'est je pense que de toute
manière à un moment ou un autre il
aurait été il aurait eu des problèmes
même sans faire de politique parce que
son parcours économique son parcours
d'homme d'affaires pouvaient prêter
quelques nombreuses affaires judiciaires
qui avaient commencé à le sursuivre
avant d'entamer cette carrière sur la
politique c'est ce qui finalement est à
commencer à écorner l'image du bonhomme
pourquoi parce qu'il est arrivé dans un
univers qui connaissait pas où il
pensait qu'il allait faire la même chose
que quand il est arrivé dans le monde
des affaires ou quand il est arrivé dans
le monde du sport parce qu'il était
arrivé dans le monde du sport il gagne
le Tour de France il est arrivé dans le
football c'est la Vie Claire avec
Bernard Hinault
1900 le dernier tour de France de
Bernard
donc il à chaque fois il gagne et là bah
d'abord il gagne pas du premier coup
parce que législatives d'abord il est
battu dans un premier temps enfin c'est
une histoire complique d'ailleurs
raconte parfaitement
et puis après les ennuis aussi qui
commencent et ils retrouvent surtout des
adversaires qui veulent sa peau là qui
là on joue plus là on est plus dans le
jeu on est c'est une question de vie ou
de mort et si il a trouvé plus fort que
lui on peut la trouver bah oui parce
qu'il s'est retrouvé dans un panier de
crabe qui oui c'est fait bouffer quoi
Marseille c'est effectivement là qu'il
entame cette carrière politique il fait
ses armes il cherche d'abord et travesti
par le
il va d'ailleurs voir tout bon à
l'époque qui secrétaire général du RPR
cet investiture à Marseille pour des
législatives du rusé par le RPR est-ce
que vous le connaissez la moindre
consciente politique à Bernard tape
beaucoup parlé avec lui j'en ai pour
parler
savoir exactement où est ceci ou il se
situait et en fait c'était pas le
problème il y a une chose c'est que si
la générosité ça c'est il y a deux
choses la générosité c'est à dire qui
généreux avec le peuple d'où il venait
faut pas oublier que son père était
ouvrier que sa mère était une femme
modeste aussi il vient d'un milieu très
vaste il est dans le 20e arrondissement
vraiment très modeste donc ça c'est le
premier pilier je dirais de sa vie et le
deuxième pilier c'est gagner et pour
vous le connaissiez pas de conviction
politique non non pour gagner tous les
moyens sont bons quoi la fin justifie
tous les rien et en politique il
comprend politique non alors là où il a
été il est sincère et ça rejoint
d'ailleurs le quand je disais que
généreux c'est que à l'époque le Front
national avait une image qui était quand
même assez même c'est des tracteurs lui
reconnaissent une chose c'est que la
seule ligne de conduite qu'il ait eu
dans sa carrière politique c'était de
lutter contre le Front national
rassemblement national aujourd'hui et un
certain Jean-Marie Le Pen c'était un
adversaire pratique parce que justement
ça lui permettait de mettre en valeur sa
gouaille c'était de mettre en valeur son
énergie ça lui permettait de mettre en
valeur il avait un adversaire à sa
mesure là et et c'est vrai que dans
certains débats
il a pris le dessus sur Jean-Marie Le
Pen alors après avoir frappé à la porte
du RPR pour une investiture au
législative il va frapper à celle de
Mitterrand c'est Jacques Séguéla on l'a
très bien vu dans ce documentaire qui
fait se rencontrer les deux hommes on
est en 1997 tapis Mitterrand c'est
vraiment un couple improbable au
possible réel complicité néanmoins entre
les deux hommes ou alors un choix
purement opportuniste d'un côté comme de
l'autre bah là on touche au plus profond
de chacun des deux bonhommes Mitterrand
avait besoin de tapis parce que là on
est dans les années où
Mitterrand est accusé de s'éloigner du
socialisme socialiste c'était les années
80 83 et puis après bon hein c'est les
années où Mitterrand
son image est quand même pas
extraordinaire même si il a été réélu en
c'est tonton mais il a besoin d'une
fibre populaire et pour cette fibre
populaire il prend deux types qui sont
extraits des milieux populaires
Bérégovoy comme premier ministre pas
immédiatement après
deux jours a été ouvriers et
vendeurs de télévision et il prend tapis
et il prend ses deux là qui sont assez
complices d'ailleurs qui savent très
bien ce que fait Mitterrand et
Mitterrand se sert d'eux ils sont ils
sont ils sont
instrumentalisés mais ils se laissent
instrumentaliser par Mitterrand parce
que pour eux c'était inespéré jamais il
pense il pensait que donc on peut donc
parler d'opportunisme des deux côtés des
deux côtés
tapis quand il est devient ministre il
pleure quasiment en pleurs alors vous
l'avez dit en 88 élections législatives
on l'a vu dans le documentaire on
l'envoie dans une circonscription que la
sixième circonscription de Marseille à
Bouches-du-Rhône dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône un gagnable sur le
papier il la gagnera finalement alors
pas du premier coup c'est vrai mais
finalement le Conseil constitutionnel
invalidera la première élection bref il
est élu député bel et bien cette fois en
janvier 89 pourquoi ne se présente-t-il
pas dans la foulée pour capitaliser sur
cette victoire sur cette gagne aux
municipales de Marseille qui suivront un
peu plus tard dans cette année 1989 bon
d'abord
un peu tôt un peu tôt et puis il est
aussi à ce moment là il rachète Adidas
il y a le rachat d'Adidas il rachat
d'Adidas c'est bien c'est là où ces
ennuis commencent parce que ça se mêle
et ça ça s'entrechoque avec son entrée
dans la carrière politique non en
revanche ce qui est sûr c'est que
si il brique pas la mairie de Marseille
dans un premier temps il pense plus tard
il y a pensé jusqu'à la fin de sa vie je
vais vous dire à la mairie de Marseille
la mairie de Marseille c'était son truc
il est pas marseillais pour un sous il
est parisien
certes il est il a acheté l'OM mais ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que jusqu'à la fin
de sa vie et on l'a vu quand il y a eu
ses obsèques il est adoré par par les
Marseillais il aurait pu être mère de
Marseille et quand à la fin de sa vie il
a été atteint d'un cancer de plusieurs
cancers et qui a eu des élections
municipales qui ne pouvaient plus
honnêtement se présenter il avait un
candidat en tête je dirais pas mais il
avait il savait celui qui l'aurait mis
pour aller jusqu'au bout c'était Renaud
Muselier le bilan de tapis à la tête du
ministère de la ville il y en a-t-il
seulement un non il y a beaucoup de
parlotes il y a beaucoup d'idées par
l'autre qui est un de ces expressions
favoris et d'ailleurs dans le
documentaire on le voit ou parler
blablablabla mais lui aussi il parle
beaucoup mais il a pas le temps de faire
ce qui sont son titre de gloire pour lui
c'est ces espèces de écoles des écoles
de la deuxième chance vous savez donc
une formation que vous offrez à des des
jeunes qui n'ont pas eu l'occasion
d'aller à l'école ou qui sont au chômage
qui sont au fond du trou et vous les
remettez en selle mais bon
le résultat est quand même assez limité
alors Bernard Tapie député cette fois a
deux reprises pas grand chose ilégera en
grande partie d'ailleurs parmi les non
inscrits autrement dit par définition
des élus qui
n'apparaissent pas qui ne jouent pas
réellement un rôle dans le débat
législatives il s'ennuie aussi donc
c'est pas c'est pas son truc et je vais
vous dire une chose il est rattrapé par
l'affaire Adidas quand la ferradine
assez éclate et ça c'est ça qu'il
l'occupe c'est ce qui occupera toute sa
vie d'ailleurs toute la fin de sa vie
toute la fin de de sa vie sera
complètement
monopolisé concentré sur cette histoire
par cette histoire qui est une histoire
qui
occupera aussi l'actualité de façon
régulière quoi le sommet politique
devient ta vie c'est 94 alors le soleil
tente une OPA peut-être sur le MRP alors
le mouvement des radicaux de gauche mais
il va toujours une liste européenne qui
obtiendra un excellent score nous sommes
bêtes sa carrière politique c'est
effectivement les élections européennes
de 1900 94 c'est la dernière torpille de
Mitterrand vis-à-vis de Rocard
exactement 1994 il est candidat
avec une liste où il y a bristelalong il
y a des écologistes il y a effectivement
des radicaux de gauche bon madame
Taubira qui sera le 4e position
cette liste et là mais il
chatouille je dirais au mollet Michel
Rocard qui lui conduit la liste des
socialistes et on se dit mais il peut
être le futur candidat de la gauche à la
présidentielle il s'y voyait il s'y
voyait et c'est il fait la Une
d'ailleurs des magazines notamment la
une du Nouvel Obs où on le voit en
président de la République avec la photo
officielle et c'est là où le parti
socialiste commence aussi se dit qu'il
faut le torpiller à tout prix et ils
vont s'y employer et ça fait partie de
de l'affaire Adidas en fait ils vont se
servir de cette affaire là pour le
torpiller mais il se présentera pas en
1994 et
l'élection présidentielle il n'en
parlera pas tu sais quoi la quête de
Bernard Tapie en politique l'idée
c'était le match fallait qu'il gagne
l'élection après
et ce qui ce qui était important c'était
qu'il montre qu'il puisse gagner
l'élection une élection alors pour finir
il laisse à sa veuve Dominique Tapie qui
a beaucoup compté hein dans son
existence à Bernard Tapie une importante
dette qui s'élèverait à 642 millions
d'euros bien ce que oblige cette
dernière à avant de l'ensemble de ses
biens pour rembourser dont seulement 143
millions d'euros ont été payés en avril
2023 il y a donc quelques mois
non ça c'est le commentaire parce que là
on se dit il n'a pas préparé l'avenir il
y a deux commentaires à faire d'abord
Dominique tapic est une femme qui a été
tout à fait essentielle capitale dans sa
vie sans elle il n'aurait pas été
Bernard Tapie il aurait pas été le
dernier Bernard Tapie gagneur qu'il a
été dans les années 80 et il n'aurait
pas tenu dans je dirais le tourbillon
des affaires qui l'ont qui l'ont
rattrapé à la fin de sa vie sans
Dominique Tapie je suis sûr que Bernard
Tapie n'aurait pas tenu le choc parce
que c'était terrible quand même il en
avait il avait un caractère très fort
mais Dominique Tapie était pour lui son
pilier et elle est une femme incroyable
qui laisse une telle étoile ce qui est
terrible c'est qu'il a décès il a laissé
sur la paille et finalement il est parti
il a rien prévu et demi tapis bah c'est
assez triste de savoir maintenant que
bon elle est dans cet état là elle est
dans cet état là matériellement elle est
matériellement
elle n'a pas grand chose quoi
ça doit être assez dur quand même pour
elle mais elle a été tout à fait
essentiel dans la vie de Bernard Tapie
dans sa volonté de vaincre ses maladies
et de vaincre ses oppositions merci
beaucoup d'être venu parmi nous parler
de Bernard Tapie après ce film Les mille
et une vie de Bernard Tapie votre
interview qui a été réalisé en décembre
2020 diffusé sur notre antenne en
janvier 2021 sera revoir pour tous ceux
que ça intéresse à la fois sur notre
site LCP.fr et sur notre chaîne YouTube
le site et la chaîne Youtube de de LCP
merci un grand merci à vous vos
réactions ça sera sur hashtag des Badog
merci aussi à sel massali qui m'a aidé à
préparer cette mission comme à
l'accoutumée prochain rendez-vous avec
des badox ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat très bientôt
[Musique]